well guys if you tuned in last time you
know the top ten movies that I hate but
everybody else seems to love well now
it's your revenge these are the top ten
movies that I like but everybody else
seems to hate now something a lot
emphasized before I start this list this
is very important
none of these films I think are great
films I don't love any of these films uh
but I thought they were okay I thought
they were decent films I'm glad I saw
them I acknowledge that all of them have
problems there's no like perfect film in
here though why can anyone see the
genius it's nothing like that
but I'm glad I paid the money I'm glad I
saw them on the big screen and I enjoyed
them so like I said if you didn't enjoy
them great doesn't say anything about
you about you being a jerk or an idiot
or anything like that um so like I said
you heard my spiel at the last video so
these are the top ten films that I enjoy
nobody else seems to
unbreakable now of course M night
Shyamalan I made fun of them everybody
has and I'm not going to lie there's a
lot to make fun of in this movie but the
reason I like this movie in all honesty
I think is for different reasons than
probably M night Shyamalan had I'm one
of those people I sorta get freaked out
at the idea of like fate or destiny I
think that's kind of a scary idea um not
to say it can't be whatever comforting
but I think it's kind of creepy because
well in this movie for example uh they
set up it's going to be lost boilers in
this by the way they set up that the
this is a world with superheroes and
villains and you're either born a hero
or you're born a villain and I don't
know if this movie sees that as a good
thing the ending has sent me a lot of
jackson we find out that he was meant to
be the villain and all his life he's had
this tragic horrible life you know and
he has these fragile bones and what's
his reward he gets thrown in jail he's
meant to be the bad guy he's meant to be
the other half um you know the yin again
but he's the villain you know he's the
bad guy but at least he finally belongs
he has a place and so it's this very
strange bittersweet ending and I like
the idea of a movie that's saying that
maybe the idea of destiny and fate is
not all is cracked up to be because if
someone's born just to be the bad guy
that's a fucked up plan okay that's a
really creepy idea and the ending is not
a happy ending it's this very you don't
know how to feel ending and like I said
I don't know if that's what M night
Shyamalan was going for it could be hey
he finally belongs it what a good
feeling even though it's kind of
disturbing but I saw this movie and was
sort of creeped out by it and I I loved
the few people that really liked the
twist ending um so I liked this film
I'll acknowledge there's a lot of things
that don't work I don't like he did this
weird thing where everybody's wearing
either purple or green and then the
criminals are wearing a bright color
when they make more sense to have the
criminals wear the purple or the green
and everyone else wears normal colors I
don't know it doesn't make sense he has
this weird thing with the upside down
cameras which again is obviously trying
to say something kind of lever hammered
in but nobody really knows why China
doesn't say so it's kind of pointless um
it's really annoying what someone is
using obvious it's like obvious
symbolism but you don't know what it's
supposed to symbolize but it's obviously
supposed to symbolize something but it's
not abstract enough where it's not
specific enough so it's kind of a mess
um but I like Bruce Willis I like Samuel
Jackson I like the mystery I like
finding out you don't know what's going
on and nobody's starting this off could
figure out what was going on which I
really like too I think if I watch it
again I probably would get tired of
those really slow talking dialogues I
think after a while back that I really
like because I like movies I move that
way like movies that took their time uh
maybe a little too slow but I don't know
or maybe it still holds up the bottom
line I like the story a nice huge comic
book guy I just like the the whole idea
of destiny being a really creepy idea I
don't see a lot of movies that do that
they're always pro destiny profane and
I'm not anti all that I just like
hearing from the other side and I
whether or not he was going for that I
don't know but it's interesting food for
thought so I enjoyed it number nine
punch-drunk love Paul Thomas Anderson is
one of the most interesting directors
working today he makes very interesting
movies and they're very odd in how
they're told and how they're pasted and
I think he is trying new things with how
to tell a story and essentially this is
just a basic romance I mean when you
really get down to it's just a basic
romance but it's told in such an odd way
and in such a strange uncomfortable way
in but in the sense that makes it the
most effective because the role Adam
Sandler plays still my favorite Sam a
movie I mean this this is him at his
best really does a good job
um he's so uncomfortable it's such a
mess and you're not entirely sure why
it's just this giant buildup of
insecurity and when he finally finds
someone you know he can fall in love
with and loves him it's it's such a good
feeling and I will admit a girlfriend
bringing her name it is Emily Watson uh
her coming out to him with a lil
sporadic a little weird uh I guess she
was a little off too but just the way
she serve gravitated towards him was a
little odd but the actual romance once
they were together I thought was really
nice it was really sweet but it is weird
it is very slow-moving it you know you
could argue there's a lot of symbolism
in it as well and it is definitely very
strange very out there and not your
traditional comedy but it leaves an
impact and every time I think of this
movie I just think of the overall
feeling it gave me a sort of this mix of
really uncomfortable but also really
sweet and loving and I love that mix
that's such a strange mix especially for
an Adam Sandler movie so I'm glad I'm
Sandler took a chance and did this film
every once awhile he tries to do a more
serious film he's not bad I mean he's
really not a bad dramatic actor if you
give him the right part I see him doing
Shakespeare or anything but but he's
pretty decent he's better than Jim
Carrey acting or uh know whoever else
does serious roles but I thought he did
a very good job and I like seemed in
dramatic roles
I like this film even though it was very
odd and how I move
but I like that I like stranger films I
like slower films if they keep your
interest and this won't get my interest
because I just did not know where it was
going it's not one of those films where
I say oh I know what's gonna happen you
have no idea what's gonna happen so very
basic um madam I thought was fun not
right Atlantis the lost Empire this is
bad when Disney was trying to go a
different direction with their animation
Department and I'll admit I would have
liked if they'd gone all the way if they
went for a straightforward grown-up
action film but they're still trying to
get the you know the stuff for little
kids and it's okay it's decent but it
would have been nice to see a really
hardcore you know like Indiana Jones
action adventure without so many kid
shows thrown in but what I like about it
really is
I like these characters I like the mold
guy I like the was that the teenage girl
was a boxer and like I like the guy with
the explosives they're all very strange
characters but you really grow to like a
man enjoy what they're doing and I like
the actual culture they sort of created
of Atlantis it was very
different-looking it was sort of it was
like Indiana Jones meets sort of an
alien alien ish technology Madelyn
Kingdom of the Crystal Skull and I liked
it I liked learning about this world I
like seeing the weird creatures and the
technology and the end of things they
ride what I didn't like is the same
thing a lot of people doing like I
didn't enjoy the villain I didn't enjoy
that it was just a treasure hunt it
actually seemed very out of character
once a lot of the main guys suddenly
turned bad you know of course they
turned good again but I mean when they
suddenly turned into bad guys where'd
this come from uh and yeah by the end
what they're fighting for it seemed very
phoned in I wish they could have had
something stronger they could been
fighting for outside of just this is a
treasure hunt you guys are gonna be rich
either way okay I mean just you don't
need to destroy the civilization or
whatever the half-baked plan was so I
don't like that ass but I
the last third that what they were
fighting for was really weak uh but I
thought everything else was diese I
thought what's interesting is a very
fascinating movie I liked this culture
I liked the technology I liked it felt
very Indiana Jones like to me or uh way
Thousand Leagues Under the Sea and I
sort of liked that stuff I like old
school but still futuristic technology I
sort of like that mix like what if
technology star went in in our direction
then the direction went with that we
chose you know what if it sort of went a
little bit more steampunk or something
like that so I enjoy it again not
perfect definitely not perfect but
especially on the big screen it's if you
have like a really well if you have like
a really big ass TV or a great sound
system watch this movie on the big
screen cuz it looks awesome um that
might be why I wanna get on blu-ray if
it is on blu-ray I'm sure it is if not
put it on blu-ray because it looks great
so very uh very underrated I think a lot
of people don't like it because of that
third act because of the you know of
what they're ultimately trying to get
out of it which is weak it's really weak
but I really like this movie it I see
more of the problems now but I really
enjoyed it back then I think it holds up
well enough it's sometimes a little too
childish but I think it works
number seven ham cock again not a
perfect movie it has problems but it is
also a very different look at
superheroes it's not a straight up
comedy it's not a straight up superhero
film that's part of the problem that
people have a thought it was a little
too jumbled it was a little - it didn't
know what it want to be on some level I
agree but on another level I think that
took in a very interesting direction
it's what if a superhero really did
exist but he was very unlikable he was a
drunk there's only one of him which is
very interesting usually it's a world
where tons superheroes live if you're
gonna the answer this comedic take on it
but no there's only one of him
supposedly spoilers um
but I like the fact that he's not the
traditional image I love these to get a
PR guy I love Li has to go to jail I
love this is a very different take on it
and I know the problem people have is
that halfway through suddenly it becomes
more the traditional superhero movie or
even sort of a weird it even beyond a
superhero movie sort of like it goes
into like the history of the scared
Dermott but not entirely and it seems
like a film that sort of leaving it open
for a sequel and it's a shame that not
too many people liked it cuz I would
like to assume the sequel I would like
to assume more of the history of this
character or characters as we find out
um and I would like to seen it explore
it a little bit more what I did like I
didn't like how there's sort of this
semi romance going on between Will Smith
and this other character and they're
starting to explore it you don't know
where it's gonna go and at the end is
just sort of like a two minute okay
she's over there and he's doing his
thing whatever it's like no there's
there's got to be more than that you
build that up and you made that really
interesting and you just sort of yeah
whatever the sequel figured out the
sequel I that was lame uh but I like
Will Smith I like um Farren you know it
was good and I thought it was very I
thought was very interesting I thought
was sort of a cool take on the superhero
uh genre would have liked to seen it
developed a little bit more but for what
I got I was entertained and I thought
was cool
number six The Chronicles of Narnia
Prince Caspian now just guess a straight
up right now I only read one Narnia book
and I was the first one actually I
didn't even know there were more Narnia
books after the first while when the
movie came out that's why I found out
there was more like there was more I
always thought it was just one it seems
so self-contained so um I didn't know
there was more so going into this movie
I didn't read the book and I find out
more and more people who didn't read the
book usually like the movie people who
have read the book hate the movie and
that's really fascinating cuz I did talk
to people about what was left
and what they added to me it seems like
the stuff they added was pretty
interesting I like that the the oldest
boy suddenly you know he starts to get a
little cocky um I like it B he becomes
too overconfident I'll uh I really like
the temptation of the white which I
thought that was very clever
I'm very well-handled and I thought it
got it did get darker did get more
menacing and it got a little bit more
political and I like that I like
anything that sort of takes that fairy
tale aspect as sort of it grows it up a
little bit Sora makes it a little bit
more tougher and more grown-up but not
too not too extreme like the Harry
Potter movies where you know if you're a
kid reading Harry Potter
oh yeah wizards II and then if you're
reading them all in a row and you get to
the last one
Jesus dude you know I it's not like that
it's it's intense but it's not you know
too graphic it's it's not too Margie
it's about the right amount um I I don't
know where the other boats go by I sort
of do I've been people have been sort of
spoiling the books for me but I don't
care um I know they do get a little bit
more you know whatever more adult and
more it certainly takes more risk but
for the film itself imagine never read
the book and you saw on that movie Mike
it's a decent movie I was really getting
into it I got into the characters a lot
more um I like that the youngest girl
could see a slant but nobody else could
I think there's a lot of challenges of
faith in there and I like it when
whatever the real world sort of sets in
a little bit more well real narnia world
whatever I know it's fictional but I
like us or sets in a little more and
everything's not as easy as it used to
be uh the fight scenes are great I love
the villain uh kid the Caspian kid what
you know was fine although I Korea is
like a lot younger in the boy pet that
was one of the big complaint um no I
think the only thing that may have
disturbed me I don't know if it was in
the books it's when the trees are
attacking yeah I we've all seen this
haven't we you know this is from Lord of
the Rings but again what I liked about
that even though it wasn't lower the
Rings uh
when I read the two towers was it two
towers yeah the two towers had the big
attack uh and the trees are attacking I
imagined them moving more like they did
in Arnie I didn't Majan that they had
legs and arms I imagined that it was
sort of more you know Octopussy you know
the roots going claw and grab people so
I liked seeing that I thought that was
pretty cool um but yeah it's from Lord
of the Rings even if it is in the book I
know he has Lewis and Tolkien we're
friends so whatever I guess it's cool
I really enjoyed that movie I thought
get more suspenseful it got darker it
got tougher but still had that sense of
magic and had new things in it
I loved whatever the hell that giant
water thing that came out just
head-butted that guy that was awesome so
I don't know I really liked to be even
more than the first one but again I'm a
minority on this maybe cuz I didn't read
the book I was actually watching it with
someone else who didn't like the first
movie he was watching the second one
like really getting into it
I said you read the books No so maybe
people who haven't read the books would
like it more I don't know I I thought
was a lot of fun I thought was a really
cool movie but what do I number 5 Star
Trek nemesis now of course if I knew
this was going to be the last Star Trek
next generation movie I'd be pissed off
I'd be like hey come on give us
something better than this this is
really overblown but just as a Star Trek
movie it's not that bad especially
considering how bad a lot of the other
Star Trek movies got and I there's
things I really enjoy about this I enjoy
the idea of your older self versus your
younger self and if you grow up in a
different environment would you be
different do you have the you know the
genetics or the willpower to you know
stay away from this path or would you go
along this path no matter what of the
nature versus nurture and that was very
interesting and I really liked the best
of is when Picard is talking with his
younger self and they're trying to learn
from each other that's great stuff and
that's really
complex really interesting it does get a
little lost in sardis overblown action
sequences and a really over-the-top even
by star trek standards um but at the
same time you just get to see some cool
things like I liked seeing the ships
actually crash into each others I see
were like the dome light slides into the
other ship which is fucking knots in
terms of Star Trek fucking look great I
thought was really cool um some things
did go a little too far I think the data
jump from one ship to another that
stupid there's a scene where a car jumps
into a space ship that was stupid so a
lot of the action scenes are too far and
over-the-top but it also gave us some
stuff we really want to see uh I like
that what was a Riker and Troy they
finally get married I like seeing Whoopi
Goldberg again in the movies I think
even uh Wesley was in there and it it
was kind of cool seeing all these
characters together again
um but yeah there are problems it's
another they wanna go to earth destroy
everything Star Trek is one a few sci-fi
movies and shows were actually I don't
mind the political talk it's not like
Star Wars where that's sort of sci-fi
fancy this is very much hey what did
this future was real you know that there
would be political talks or would sort
of be these debates um and I would like
to little bit more of that in this Star
Trek instead of going for so much action
uh for the stuff that's in it though
despite how stupid it can get could get
really stupid the stuff that works I
think really works and a lot of that
comes to the to Picard's I'd like the
families to data is also I found that
interesting but like everyone else I was
pissed off it wasn't war oh my god such
a Star Trek deep right now but I was
pissed off it wasn't war as sort of this
you know mentally off data which I know
they're going for at the end it's like
he's replacement could come back again
sort of live through him all that good
stuff
interesting that really that developed
um but I like that sort of like wait was
starting to deal with I like what do
with Picard may I would like to see a
little bit more that would data maybe so
uh
the last film it's not a good last you
know next-generation film if that was
going to be the last one it's like come
on you can do better than that but it's
decent I'm glad I saw it had some good
action some good effects and not totally
devoid of character so unlike some of
your Star Trek movies which I think the
only the only Star Trek movie it had
nothing good in it like at all was
insurrection in my opinion now because
it's like it has the worst moment it's
just totally forgettable
so but every Star Trek movie has
something good as something that made
you glad to see it and that's pretty
cool so I think nemesis had there was
more to it than I think some people gave
credit for but just gets so shadowed by
those over-the-top action sequences and
some of the Dumber moments that I think
people just sort of forget it but I'll
watch it again that there's some good
stuff in there anything number four the
Cable Guy this is said to be the movie
that almost destroyed Jim Carrey's
career which is so ironic cuz it wasn't
a bomb it did okay but it was so out of
character what Jim Carrey I guess
normally does or the tone was it was a
much darker tone it was directed by Ben
Stiller I thought that was a movie that
almost destroyed his directing career I
thank God he came back with a traffic
Thunder and to Zoolander's Barry fine
too um but so many people hate how dark
it is and sort of how semi mean-spirited
it is it especially compared to comedies
today it's not that bad and I think the
only thing is sort of hard to stomach
with is Jim Carrey's acting sometimes
can get a little grating but but he also
managed to capture the annoyance of some
of these people I think everybody has
had a friend like this if you if you
don't like this movie you have not had a
friend like this this is the kind of
friend that just does not get the idea
will not leave you alone will not give
you your space
is usually very socially awkward and you
know gotta help I'm sure they're great
people but this is for people that have
had this friend this is her what we
think might be going on nothing by
people at home just calling over and
over maybe a spiders probably
they're facing to end it just it cracked
me up and I think the scene there's a
scenery sake on the phone and like I
said there's a spider crawls across his
face and people might have been thinking
wow that's really creepy that's really
dark I thought that was really funny I
think that was meant to be funny you
know it's just so over the top and I
don't know I I guess I sort of known
people like this I know other people I
have and I think at horrible to say
after I've gotten the internet fame I
think of no more people like this but
it's really I thought it really captured
just how creepy some of these people can
be and just how over-the-top our
imagination can go with us now of course
in this movie he really is doing all
this weird stuff but it's a comedy it's
an over-the-top comedy and for me and I
think a lot of people to have or have
friends like this it's fun to think
maybe this is what's going on in their
head and its total self-indulgence it's
not fair but it's it's a release okay is
it released if I got maybe they aren't
doing all this weird creepy stuff so I
liked it I thought the the satire with
Ben Stiller with the medieval times and
Janeane Garofalo is the waitress that
was great on the trial with the the two
boys from the sick on that that could be
a movie itself that was hilarious um Jim
Carrey doing the don't you need somebody
to love if that was great I don't know I
enjoyed it I thought was a lot of fun
yeah it's dark but it's not the darkest
comedy out there and agile I think
should Kerry's been darker comedies Lee
Eternal Sunshine of the spotless mind
and such so I really had fun with it I'd
you think it's a very funny comedy
number three Matrix Reloaded now let me
make one thing perfectly clear I don't
like any of the Matrix movies I don't
think any of them are technically good
movies but out of all of them the one I
dislike the least is the second one and
the second one was the only one where I
thought wow this is really doing some
big awesome stuff this is really having
fun with itself the first film had that
bullet-time great and had that idea
about a what if this world is not our
world has all a dreamer constructed it's
not the first time somebody's thought of
that guys I think that's what bothers me
it's like the matrix blew my mind it's
this isn't the first time it's been done
it's been done lot that there's sci-fi
stories short stories books leading back
to like the Stone Age they have done
this there's episode that Star Trek that
I've done this you know it's Twilight
Zone for God's sake you know have done
this so I I guess a little bother that
you got as big recognition as it did and
then for being so revolutionary and it's
if you watch it now it's so dated
the long black coats you know it looks
like goth kids yeah I love how it's like
they're supposed to blend into their
environment
who the fuck wears long black coats and
leather and sunglasses at night who
dresses like that fail you're not
blending it at all I love the fact that
the matrix is trying to keep this a
secret as well whatever the computers
get they're jumping on cars flipping
them over and disappearing and
transporting this is the worst get
secret in the world but that I like this
movie the second one I like mainly
because the big complaint everybody has
is that well there's no character to it
you know there's no development at all
well I hated the characters in the first
film I thought they were bland I thought
they were boring all the second film is
is action and philosophy I like action
and philosophy so I enjoy to spell whysa
I can't say it's good but I as a lot of
things aren't really good really hold up
the action scenes are incredible they're
starting to look a little fake now but I
like the highway chase really really
good stuff
the fight with all the Smiths the agents
miss I think see they really should say
that from the last movie because I think
they played their trump card too early
that would have been a good final battle
what's the last battle like they're all
watching and he fights the one makes no
sense um but that would have been a good
final battle feels just fighting a
bajillion of them and you know the
philosophy was fun when they're talking
about it it did seem like that action
philosophy action philosophy
I don't mind cuz I didn't like the
characters um in the first film it
seemed very much the first half talk
Tata Tata Tata Talk was the major this
is the major that I'm a second half five
papa fight action action for the throw
some stuff punch and I don't think it
was paced very well it's sort of like
Kill Bill actually except in Reverse
first half is like nothing but talk
second half nothing but action and you
need to pace it out I thought the second
was a little bit better paced out um did
I understand what that guy was saying
when he's in that big computer room
though you know whatever you were the
subject of first of many the first of
blah blah blah I don't know what the
fuck he's saying like everyone else I
didn't care um I thought the big reveal
like everyone else was gonna be that
there's a matrix inside the matrix would
have been awesome no um but I like the
idea that to kill the virus he has to
sort of become the party has to whatever
be absorbed by I thought that can
clobber but I digress uh the second film
I thought had good action has some good
philosophy I didn't give a crap about
the character that I didn't know the
first one anyway so the least I could
save them I could see them the better I
like Hugo Weaving it's the bad guy he's
a lot of fun there's much more of him in
the second one so I enjoy that uh third
one was shit I can be just totally
forgettable I don't remember a thing
about it you know I guess a except how
it ended but uh and the first one I
think is a good idea the only thing I
remember that was really clever about
the first one was when when the kid says
you had to realize the spoon isn't there
that was very clever that that's you can
play around a lot with that in terms of
philosophy um
but everything else I thought was very
textbook and very seen it before but uh
the second one I thought was doing a lot
of really
cool really new things even more than
the first one
oddly enough and I guess people couldn't
get into it because I guess they really
did like the characters in the first one
they want to see a more interesting
story and I guess it was just whatever
fighting a philosophy I understand that
I guess I just don't see why people love
the first one so much right sir I do but
the second one was the one that was the
most fun for me because like I said I
don't care about the story I don't care
about the characters it's sort of like
my play video game I just want to blow
shit up and see some pretty visuals
that's why the gun the second one so I I
enjoyed it
number two spider-man 3 alright you all
saw my top 11 donut spider-man moment so
you know that there's a lot of things to
hate about spider-man 3 but you also
know I like the movie and you're
probably wondering what the hell do you
like about spider-man 3 well I'll tell
you exactly what I liked the big thing
for me was this was the first time I
actually gave a crap about the romance
in the last two films it seemed very
force very awkward very although they're
talking they're sharing moments yay you
know and then oh well they get together
will they want yeah we know they will
now that they're together that's where
the interesting stuff starts I like that
it's sort of a switch around now Mary
Jane is getting crapped on now Peter is
getting all the glory and I like that
sort of goes to his head and he you can
understand he doesn't get this
recognition that much he's finally being
praised for his good deeds and he lets
it goes to you know go to his head and
he overstepped his bounds I like that I
thought that was very realistic it for a
spider-man movie you know and but the
other thing that I really liked is that
uh Mary Jane finally you know is trying
to become this three-dimensional
character and she has problems too and
nobody in this relationship was just
right or wrong it's that she's having
these problems she needs someone there
to support her you know like she's been
there to help support him and he can't
be there and that is a typical
relationship problem that someone needs
support and the other person can't be
there there's just too much going on and
it's the first time I felt
like yeah I'm concerned I want to see
them stay together but these are real
issues you know this okay nobody goes up
dressed like a spider and stops crying
but I mean being occupied with something
else and I thought they were addressing
that really well and like I said Peter
gets carried away with himself he starts
to sort hit on that gwen stacy check and
like i said he but he's got to ask her
to marry him so in his mind it's like
she i'm gonna ask her to marry me what
there's no this once prisons nothing
yeah she's pretty but whatever and i
like that i like that he's so confident
he thinks as she's on the same level
that she is just as confident as he is
and she's not and again this is a very
typical relationship problem i found
that all very interesting um the other
thing I like is that I like where they
were starting to go with the costume you
know taking over his personality and
making him darker I like that I thought
that was a cool setup I like Harry
forgetting his memory I like uh you know
trying to become friends again I like
him trying to regain his memory and how
they sir want to they want him to get it
back but they also want to keep it
separate now here's a big thing when I
saw this movie I saw it twice and there
is always three moments in the movie
that everybody gasps at everybody goes
boom the one is when Peter almost loses
the ring fighting Harry another is when
Mary Jane kisses Harry and then the
other is when Peter hits Mary Jane
everything every time I saw a movie
everybody went oh now if a movie makes
an audience gasps three times it's doing
something right it has people invested
for me where the movie starts will go
downhill is as soon as Harry gets his
memory back that's when the Platteville
start that's when things don't make
sense that's when it becomes really
forced and contrived uh you know as I
said before he forces Mary Jane to break
up with Peter why doesn't she just tell
him that Harry has his memory bag go
beat him up
you know he's spider-man he'd go he goes
and does that anyway and even after that
how come she never comes forward with it
um how come you know why does he turn so
goofy and silly when he has the black
Alfa
no that was fourth why wasn't there more
venom um and here's my another really
big problem at the very end you know he
talks with the Sandman I like the story
behind the Sandman by the way I like
that they made him very interesting I
like the daughter thing I like why he's
a criminal I was trying to save his
daughter I thought that was very
interesting and it wasn't totally
half-assed or anything they do try to
show the development he they do a lot of
stuff without having to talk about all
the time which I like the second one
didn't do that one as much you know the
second was a lot of talking here they
can just show it I like when he just
sits down it looks as daughter that was
effective but at the end after he turns
into the monster goes burn I can't speak
English anymore um he talks to Peter
Parker and he says what really happened
with the uncle and I didn't need to do
it and blah blah blah Parker says I
forgive you big scene and the Sandman
says all that matters now is my daughter
and he blows away in the wind where the
fuck is he going
is he gonna rob another Bank are they
just gonna fight again what happens with
his daughter what's the resolution that
I got really invested in the daughter
how can we never know what happens so
that really annoyed me and the other
thing I knowing me is that at the very
end with every spider-man movie you sort
of feel like he's growing up a bit and
with this one that they went through the
relationship problems but I didn't feel
like anything happened that brought them
closer they were going through the
problems that's going the ideas that you
had to work your way through it to grow
more uh but I don't feel they ever did
what they saved her from a building
again that fixes everything I didn't get
that so and then I sort of felt was a
step backwards you know that nothing's
really evolved it's like they start to
confront these questions but they never
went all the way through with this or
that disappoint me but the stuff the
stuff that's good in this movie oh my
god that I forgot the scene where the
sane man comes to life for the first
time unbelievable never seen a scene
like that I mean it sounds like a short
film that the music the imagery the
visuals not one word is said and it's
just this incredible moment I'm just
always shocked when people say
shit nothing good in it that moment
alone she like won its own little mini
Oscar I mean that was just unbelievable
and I guess that's why I'm so shocked
when people say they don't like it
because yeah the stupid moments are
really stupid and maybe maybe Raimi just
did overshoot it with what he could get
away with but God the moments that are
good are just phenomenal
so I his practice being an optimist
because as you can see I really do see
the bad moments as well but the moments
that are good I think are just so good
so like I said there's good moments bad
moments I I personally think the good
moments Trump the bed and the number one
movie that I like but everyone else
seems to hate is x-men 3 yeah another
three movie isn't it something about the
second sequel always turns people off
maybe people are tired of it I don't
know but I like this film though again
problems big problems but what I enjoy I
guess I like now it is sort of a very
selfish nature uh I enjoyed seeing
Kelsey Grammer as beast when he was on
screen I'm like there he is that's beast
totally realized perfect actor looks
perfect awesome it was the same feeling
I got when I saw Hugh Jackman as
Wolverine it's like there he is one my
childhood icons on the screen alright so
Michael Keaton is Batman it's like no no
that's not actor playing Batman that's
Batman it was the same thing when I saw
Beast and it just gave me chills it was
cool to see him jump around and beat the
shit out of people but still be an
intellectual loved it um but there's
hard stuff I really liked it was the
first x-men movie where I thought shit
was finally happening and the first film
you can understand because it's set up
it's establishing and the second film
though I like it okay was just moving so
slowly and still giving it's like the
Harry Potter movies it's like we'll give
you a tablet of information and the rest
is just sort of filler I like the fact
this is a movie where finally shit was
getting done characters were dying you
know people were drawing lines in the
sand and choosing sides
and I liked that there's been so much
build-up for it in these movies and this
is the movie that
finally gave it but again it doesn't
amount to much I think that's my biggest
problem is that the whole movie is sort
of build up and things are happening but
what it ultimately comes out to is not
very satisfying uh bringing Jean Grey
back great I second film you saw the
Firebird you saw the Phoenix awesome
can't wait for it what she's just nuts
schizo here's the thing here's what I
thought I didn't need to see whatever
cuz in the comic it's like aliens come
down it was a big alien thing um I
didn't need to see that what I thought
they were going to do I thought that
with you know mutation mutants are the
next evolution of man got it
I thought maybe she was going to be the
next evolution of mutant like nobody
else exists like you know fur there's
always that jump and then one of them
got this even bigger jump and I thought
that would have been interesting but no
she's just whatever a class-five and
they're there's a couple of them that
exist uh and it seemed kind of pointless
to bring her back just to kill her again
I why'd you bring her back anyway um but
it was cool to see it was still cool to
see the Phoenix do what the Phoenix does
you know the eyes glow the Serve things
fly up it looks fiery I wish they could
have done something fiery and that's why
show the Firebird if you're not going to
add but that was lame um but to see the
house rise up and to see xavier rise up
and just her blowing the shit of
everything I mean I thought what's
really cool and I've always wanted to
see the Phoenix on the big screen and
that's I thought it was pretty cool not
entirely satisfied but pretty damn close
could have been a lot worse um I like
how this is the first time the action
scenes we're feeling it's the first X
movie that felt epic it felt huge like
hey shit is really mattering here and
again with the first film you're setting
it up got it with the second film Jean
died Oh No
you know this is the first time where
you felt like this is a good dilemma
this is good
um you know this is a good argument to
have if this cure really did exist you
know would you take it would it be
ethical to take it and he took chances
it had Rogo and she changed magneto is
now changed apparently maybe not all
these characters are getting killed uh
but their characters I don't care for
that much so I didn't mind too much like
I say it's sort of a selfish reason you
know never care much for Cyclops I
didn't care to see him go uh Xavier was
sad but whatever didn't care to seem go
Jean I never care that much more didn't
care of seeing her go so but it's like
things were happening it's finally like
yes big shit is adding up but in the end
what did it amount to
it didn't really amount to anything no
clear definition was Mabel and maybe a
little bit rogue getting her powers
taken away I felt was very that was a
big risk and I thought it did pay off I
thought that was very clever that it's
like hey we're not gonna push out and
say hey this side is right or her it's
ambiguous whatever it's sort of people
are just going to see what they see and
people are just going to make their
choices and it sort of has to be
respected you know you have to see it
from their side and I like that I love
it when uh what was it the ice boy Ice
Man whatever says you know that this
isn't what I want she said this is what
I wanted I thought that really set it up
pretty well but people are just going to
have their opinions and we just got to
you know respect slash understand it um
with that said a lot of things I don't
like well is the point of arcangel no
reason um you have this opening with him
as a kid why have that he's not a big
character um Wolverine no more as
explained about his backstory again
killing gene at the end why why was she
back um but again it was nice to see
magneto is finally turning into a real
bad guy it's not super the first film
you're almost sort of like yeah I think
they can see that yeah you know you
sympathize with him and the only reason
you know he's the bad guys because
there's an error in the plan you know
that the Machine kills people aside from
that's not a bad plan yeah it's forcing
this on people that's not right but it's
not that evil
second filming started to get a little
evil with trying to destroy the people
okay that's best turning into a bag and
in third film he's the badass he's the
villain this is Magneto this is the
magneto I was waiting for I don't know
and none of these feel now the x-men
films I think are great films but I do
enjoy them I think all of them are okay
uh but yeah the third one was the first
one where I just felt like shit was
being done shit was happening I wish it
could have had a more satisfying
conclusion uh but even then I don't
think it was terrible I like did this
drug work maybe it did maybe it didn't
you know um and I I thought it took for
an x-men movie I thought took a lot of
risks and a lot of people just felt they
didn't pay off I sort of thought they
did I thought some of the choices they
made were very weak and and they weren't
very good but for it finally felt like
the x-men movie I wanted to see the big
ax men movie you know not the a we're
setting it up were setting up no this is
the big ship that bridge is being moved
you know magneto takes a trunk of
Schumer and tosses it aside and you know
this is what I was waiting for so
juggernaut holy fuck was he awesome so I
I was very happy to see a lot of these
characters and a lot of these action
scenes and I like the story I like the
dilemma I thought was more realistic too
uh nowadays how prejudice is being dealt
with I thought with the first film is
sort of you know we hate them again
seeing that a million times I like how
this one it's mutants are a little bit
more accepted I like how beast is on you
know whatever he's on some sort
political board or something he was an
advisor and I like how there's this big
dilemma whether or not people should
take this choice or not and it just
seems a little bit more where we are now
it's like these people are little people
are more accepting of you know
homosexuals and so forth and people a
different culture
is there were more accepting of course
you're always gonna get the a-hole
that's like fuck'em but for the most
part we're much more accepting and I
like the Fed that this movie sort of
acknowledges that it's not like we're
going back to whatever like the 50s or
something like that where prejudice was
just a okay
you know I think people are more
accepting they at least want to be more
accepting that they want to be more open
so I like the fan this movie did sort of
take that level it wasn't the generic we
hate mutants now it's you know it's more
accepted now it's what do we do what are
the right choices and I had I enjoyed it
I see the problems but I've really
enjoyed it I like watching it I think
it's a lot of fun it's a good action
flick it raises good questions
the characters are decent has problems
like I said I don't like the way it all
resolves itself but I thought if they're
the Wolverine so folks those are the top
ten movies that I like everyone else
seems to hate hopefully you can see that
these movies and and what I think of
them it doesn't say anything like hey
you're a terrible person you're a great
person
it's just opinion it's just how you
explain it that really was the purpose
of these two videos if you like a movie
that nobody else likes enjoy it if you
hate a movie everyone else loves hate it
it's fine you know if you can explain it
I think if you can have people
understand why you don't like something
that's a very good way of being more
open and having them sort of understand
hey this is like a war you know over
what's good and what's crap so I don't
maybe this you know will help you out of
it but leave some of the other movies in
the comments tell me movies that
everyone disagrees with you on that just
films that you enjoy everyone else hates
or you hate everyone else enjoys and
explain why I think that's the biggie if
you write something like I know what it
likes x-men three's a day or so that's
that's troll I mean you know did do
something that explains why this film
meant something to you because you can't
stop somebody from you know having a
film mean something to you were having a
film offend you you know all you can do
is
hear their side and see if that also
affects you as well so guys I hope you
enjoyed this video I had a lot of fun
talking about this everybody take care